الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب خرج
امس من جلسه الاستدعاء للمحكمه الفيدراليه
في ميامي من دون قيد ولا كفاله ترامب
يواجه 37 تهمه جنائيه بخصوص احتفاضه
بوثائق وسجلات حكوميه وعسكريه من فتره
رئاسته اخذها معاه بعد ما انتهت ولايته في
20 21
السلطات لقيت الوثائق في منزل ترامب في
فلوريدا وبتقول انه هذا غير قانوني وهو
بيقول انه حق مطلق انه ياخذها وعنده هو
تبريراته للموضوع قبل ما هذا كله يصير
ترامب كان قال انه الوثائق مو معاه وبعدين
رفض انه يرجعها وقت طلبوها منه رسميا
واتهموا بالتامر لعرقله عمل المحققين اللي
كانوا بيسعوا لاستعاده الوثائق بعدين
سلمها يعني المهم امس استدعي ترامب
للمحكمه وراح وبنذكر انه هذه المره الاولى
اللي بتوجه فيها تهم جنائيه من قبل محكمه
فيدراليه الى رئيس
نيجي لتفاصيل الجلسه واللي حابين اليوم
نمشي معاكم فيها خطوه بخطوه ونحاول نجيب
على كل الاسئله المتعلقه فيها خصوصا انه
فيها تداعيات خاصه للي مو ملمين كثير
بالنظام القضائي الامريكي واسلوبه واحنا
اليوم معانا خبير في الحلقه حيجاوبنا على
اسئلتنا طيب نرجع للقصه الجلسه دامت 47
دقيقه عنوانها الولايات المتحده ضد دونالد
ترامب لما دخل المحكمه كتار قالوا كده صار
قيد الاعتقال وحتى الناس قالوا انه قانونا
يعتبر سلم نفسه لكن عموما لمن دخل ما حطوا
له كلبشات وما اتخذت له صوره المتهمين
اللي هي معروفه بالمقشط وفي كلام متضارب
عن موضوع البصمات لو الدي ان اي لو
اتاخدوا ولا لا مثل ما دائما بيحصل مع كل
المتهمين طيب احنا معانا من عمان المحامي
المزاول في نيويورك محمد تيسير الن عيمي
اهلا فيك معانا محمد طيب خلينا اول شيء
نبتدي من قصه انه
دونالد ترامب vs
الدوله ايش يعني هذا الموضوع
اهلا ست ساره يسعد مساكي ومساء المشاهدين
الكرام مثل ما تفضلتي ببدايه عن القضيه هي
اسم القضيه كاسم هي بيانات امريكا ضد
متهمين اثنين احدهم دونالد ترامب تاتي
التسميه انه الخصم في هذه القضيه عند
قراءه اسماء اطراف الدعوه هي المملكه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كونه من يملك
حق تقديم وبدء القضايا الجزائيه بمعنى
القضايا اللي فيها جرائم هي ذراع التنفيذي
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي الحكومه
فمن هذا فمن هذا المنطلق
بتكون السلطه لدى النائب العام للولايات
المتحده وما يعادله هو وزير العدل في
البلدان العربيه النائب العام هو بعطي هاي
الصلاحيات لمن يمثلوه دوائر الادعاء العام
والنيابه العامه وفي مثل هذه الجرائم
الجرائم الجزائيه القضايا الجزائيه اللي
ما فيها حق ما بين شخص ين اثنين قرار
جزائيه بتكون هي الحكومه من هي الخصم
وبكون هو الادعاء العام اللي هو اصلا
بترافع بهذه القضيه وهو عليه عاتق اثبات
انه المشتكى عليه في مثل قضيتنا دونالد
ترامب هو مذنب وهو ارتكب هايل هاي الجريمه
لما بنقول انه هو رهن الاعتقال وسلم نفسه
هذه اوصاف دقيقه
يعني مو دقيقه مئه بالمئه لانه يعتمد على
الانطباع اللي عند الناس احنا اذا بنحكي
هو رهن الاعتقال معناه هو مقيد او في مكان
لا يمكن الخروج منه ولكن هو طوع نفسه
وامتفل امام المحكمه وقبل بولايتها عليه
بحيث انه كانت حريته اللي اعطاها الدستور
مقيده يعني ما بقدر يطلع من المحكمه لازم
يمتثل للاوامر اللي بتحكي له اياها
المحكمه لازم يمثل امام المحكمه ولازم لما
المساله المحكمه تساله اسئله يجاوب عليها
فمنقدر نحكي انه حريته كانت مقيده نوع هذا
التقييد عام احنا بنسميه ارست يعني هو زي
رهن الاعتقال ولكن باخذ اكثر من شكل
بحالتنا ما كان معتقل مقيد وداخل زنزانه
او الى ما ذلك طيب المرحله اللي جات يعني
بعد هذه محمد انه ترامب دخل خلاص وبدات
الجلسه وفيها انقرا لائحه الاتهامات اللي
ضده واللي مكونه من 44 صفحه بعدين اقر
بانه غير مذنب في التقاضي الامريكي في
معروف انه في شيء اسمه الاقرار بالذنب او
قلت هذا بلي وانه المتهم في اول المراحل
بيقول هو شايف نفسه مذنب او لا خلينا
نسالك اكثر ونفهم هذه جزئيه محمد ايش
بتعني انه قال نط قلتي او غير مذنب وايش
بيترتب عليها
نعم 60 مثل ما تفضلتي تبدا اجراءات
المحاكمه المتعلقه بالجزاء لما يكون في
جرائم اول جلسه بتكون يحضر المشتكى عليه
او المتهم وبساله بساله قاضي مو شرط يكون
نفس القاضي راح ينظر القضيه اول اشي بشرح
له ايش هي التهم المسنده اليه بتاكد اذا
كان تبليغه صحيح بخصوص التهم وثالثا هو
بساله هل انت مذنب ام غير مذنب وهذا
السؤال مصير جدا لانه احنا زي ما بنعرف
اذا عمل فهو اعترف والاعتراف سيد الادله
ففي حال اذا قال هو مذنب يفقد حقه يضمن له
اياه الدستور الامريكي بالتعديل رقم سته
وهو انه لا يجوز لا يجوز حكم على شخص الا
عن طريق محاكمه ويكون فيه ادوار تبادل
اللوائح ويكون هاي اذا قال هو مذنب فقد
هذا الحق وتنتقل الان المحكمه الى تحديد
موعد للجلسه لاصدار الحكم بالعاده
او يعني اتفاق ما بين بكون بين الشرطه او
الادعاء العام او مثلا
مع المشتكى عليه بتحكي له اذا انت بتذنب
وبتوفر علينا عناء سنوات من القضاء وسنوات
من الشهود والخبره ممكن يفوز ممكن يخسر
اذا بتنذب احنا بنقدر نعمل لك
تخفيف للعقوبه ولهم هذا الحق انهم يخففوا
العدو اذا كان في اتفاق بيسمى
اذا ما كان في اتفاق بالعاده بقول مذنب او
غير مذنب اذا حكم مذنب انتهت الاجراءات
بصير في تحقيق موعد اصدار الحكم بعد ما
ترم قال انه غير مذنب يعني صار في نقاش
مطول بين محامين وبين الادعاء والقاضي حول
قيود معينه عليها خلال فتره المحاكمه
بعدها افرج عنه بتعهد شخصي ومن غير كفاله
وحتى نساعد الادعاء لو يبغى يتحفظ على
جواز سفر ترامب قالوا لا كيف نفسر محمد
سبب الافراج من غير كفاله وليه ما طالبوا
مثلا بجوا ز سفره
العمل بتاعه الان اشي وبجيز وهو ما حب
يخلق اي اي اشياء ممكن تؤثر على القضيه
للامام بالاضافه بالاضافه الا انه دونالد
ترامب شخص اعلن نيته الترشح للانتخابات
يعني راح يضلوا بالولايات المتحده وثانيا
هو شخص معروف هو شخص معروف جدا ومن السهل
التعرف على اقامه
في هذا الموضوع وبدا هو كمان طبعا اي شيء
يقوله فهذه القصه حتكون بتخليه يا منحاز
لترمب يا منحاز للترامب وسيتم تحويل
السياسيه لكن زي ما انت ذكرت يعني محمد
انه في نهايه الجلسه هذه القاضي فعلا تنفس
الصعداء ومزح وقال انه انا سعيد جدا انه
دوري انتهى في القضيه او المراحل الجايه
حتكون مع قاضيه ثانيه طيب اذا تقول لنا بس
انه ليش في قضيه ثانيه حتكون في المرحله
الجايه وايش المنتظر في الجلسه هذه اللي
جايه
نعم سيدتي مثل ما تفضلتي بمقدمتك هاي اول
قضيه ضد ضد رئيس ولايه المتحده اسبق في
المحاكم الفيدراليه يعني على مستوى على
مستوى اتحادي وقوانينها تطبق على كامل
ولايات اللي يشكلوا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بالعاده اول اجراءات وهي
شرحناها الامتثال للمحكمه واخذ الصوره
والبصمات والسؤال المتهم اذا كان مذنب او
لا بالعاده تقوم فيها المحكمه المركزيه في
نفس المقاطعه بعد هذا الاجراء تحول القضيه
الى قاضي مختص في حالات بكون بتحول
بالقرعه بنظام الكتروني في حالات بتكون
صلاحيات رئيس المحكمه بحول القضيه عند
القاضي المختص الان القاضي المختص راح
تبلش اجراءات المحكمه وهو لانه قال انا
غير مذنب بلشنا اجراءات المحكمه ببلش
الادعاء العام اللي هو الخصم في هذه
القضيه سوف امريكا بيبلش بتقديم
البينات تعونه والادله اللي تعاونوه
وبعدين ببلش بالشهود تعونه بس تخلص فتره
الادعاء العام بتبلش فتره الدفاع وهي فتره
ترامبول المحامين تاعه بيقدموا ادلتهم
بيقدموا دفوعهم يستجيبوا هم الشهود وطبعا
احنا بنعرف هاي القضيه فيها جوري فيها
هيئه محلفين فيها هيئه محلفين حيكون مكونه
من عدد كبير فالمحكمه هديك راح تشرع بكامل
اجراءات القضيه نسمع كل الادله
الدراما الحقيقيه يعني حنعيش الاجواء
الدراميه
[موسيقى]